[Music]
welcome back to off-the-record where we
talk about why so what do you want to
talk about oh I was so excited about the
intro oh you know what I've been doing I
think you guys jack it up you just told
this off-camera yeah you're jacking off
a lot a lot you said a lot is it extra
yeah [ __ ] Jenny Perry senior numbers
are way up yeah seven times a day I
didn't say all that I remember what part
did you say that Bart said Bitcoin went
up and then Joe said my jackoff numbers
of normal I didn't say that what did you
say what did you say repeat what you
said I said snooze that was the last
time you got a late and I was like it's
been a long time buddy
he goes oh you've been jacking off huh
and it was like you're a jackoff Steve
said hey man when was the last time you
got laid and then you said a really long
time ago
I've been jacking off and we're like
nobody asked you that [ __ ] a lot well
guess what Steve maybe didn't say that
but my job rang Steve said that and it
came out of my mouth all right wait Joe
brain has people inside help Steve get
out how do you think I stay occupied for
two weeks
we don't do [ __ ] during JK news and you
guys like just gonna go crazy
if you can't handle this [ __ ] and I'm
more like you don't know what happens in
my brain beer dude yes how do you think
I stay so like I don't miss you guys
feels good so here's the thing don't
worry we're just hangin out I was just
wondering if he ever had arguments with
his people
oh yeah I've heard him had Joe's room
and hear his arguments his own room yeah
a mother [ __ ] what happened
nothing personal do you but I think that
Joe brain Julian never made it out of
the company yeah I think she still works
here and I told you this to multiple
times you and you leave it and you leave
comments on my Instagram saying that I
never
like hey I haven't seen you in a long
time can you like say hi and come to my
office next time listen girl people
don't leave me okay
I leave that I leave them I delete them
but speaking about the brain right so
there is a part of our brain called the
subconscious I've been listening to a
lot of audiobooks and things that are
basically saying the same things with by
different authors no relation and with
psychology too and the I'm doing a lot
of work on reality and perception
because that's another thing is like I
do them a lot of make-believe it's fun
right I have you guys as my imaginary
friends and you guys are my real friends
what does work on reality and perception
begin I'm still trying to I'm like
holding on right now he has the [ __ ]
time because he he basically went to war
last night with one guy who commented
[ __ ] and wrote him like a novel response
but then he doesn't know if that was
real or fake but how does he handle this
all these audiobooks I slept at midnight
okay oh well the way I listen to
audiobooks is I play them before I go to
sleep so by the time I wake up I had it
in my dream and then it continues so you
sleep reads but to really get
information down sometimes you need to
read the book of several times or
sometimes you play the audio book on
like double speed and then you flip
through the pages so you could read it
that's another good way to do it too but
goes in the audiobook of the book that
you also read yeah so you buy price
right you get to buy the book and yet
the body audio book that's maximal
absorption that's another YouTube you
can there's a lot of free books that
they just real plod yeah and you could
watch it like double speed so it's like
it's like a chipmunk is always reading
to me yeah and then you just flip the
pages and you I don't know it's it's
pretty quick because my voice in the
brain doesn't read as fast as the
audiobook double speed I don't know no
that's very normal that's the most
normal thing you've said this whole
scent this whole conversation well you
wonder how okay so yeah there's there's
a lot of things that we can multitask
doing right so like
instead of doing like like let's say
just washing dishes and maybe I'll play
music in the background I have a audio
book going while this is happening and
then I can continue that with an actual
book in between but anyways let's go
back down to reality and perception
right so in our subconscious here's the
thing like what I've been playing with
is that a lot of people think whatever
they see everyone else in the world sees
yes it's this is the truth and the only
truth right so then I see the the reason
for humans problems is because of the
disagreement of the reality so then it's
a bunch of reality is just clashing so
people think that this is my world and
you need to come into my world and
believe this because you're [ __ ]
stupid and then so I think this has has
been going on
plus the the combination of like hey I
want to I want I want to rape and
pillage and steal all your [ __ ] so those
are the two things that people are
combining is like they're trying to
fight over the reality plus take [ __ ]
now for me I'm like will this ever be
solved in human in the inhumanity like
because in order for a human to evolve
right to this point where you see that
you're doing that and you're just kind
of perpetuating a program that you had
throughout from your family and school
and all this stuff so will there ever be
a point where like there's this
collective consciousness where we get
there and we fight we figure out a
system to elevate from baby tyka which
is we go through the stages of caveman
to the renaissance or whatever we go
through these stages right if a human
doesn't do that then a human stays an
animal like if Tiger wasn't in the
society but can raise them in the jungle
whatever like you have to restart
everything yeah right so then what we
have structure we have all this stuff
and it took years to get here because
you know we had religions and and kings
and queens and all that and we had time
to figure it out and we wrote down our
history yeah but it's easy for a human
being to be reduced to animal
very [ __ ] quick and I said what is
the difference between a person that is
a civil human being and that animal and
I was like is it one self-awareness
because everyone thinks that they're
self-aware and everyone thinks they're
not getting fooled when in reality they
do they are and to how to unveil that is
it only the death of an ego hmm I am
confused but I'm also happy to be here
that make sense I love that I got to
hear it but I'm also yeah did I explain
it confusing nice manly words I I am I
am aware of from the line of things I've
read too I do the way you ended it with
the death of an animal it was like
almost like we're all supposed to be
like okay not an eagle no he said
doesn't an animal appear he said that's
the Vinita I know you said that before
me yeah yeah yeah if you really were
listening you say why are we all really
soft for where are we all really and
then I don't know we all right yeah well
are we all the product of the structure
of our society or all the all animals
inside and and if we're people then are
the is the animal inside of his death
well it goes back down to people all
think what they're doing is right and no
one is actually ever wrong so here's the
thing about the wrongest people in our
society which are criminals right none
of them actually believe that they're
wrong they're just forced into saying
that they're wrong yeah they think
society's [ __ ] up right and this is
human nature which justifies what
they're doing yes it's just perspective
well you believe that though real
quickly to counterpoint you then why
have a Department of Corrections because
you can never correct somebody who never
believes they did wrong like I think
that people actually think that they
they know when they've done wrong it's
just they don't want everyone else to
know they've done wrong sometimes it
could be but there's a constant
justification because at the end of the
day no one can accept that they're wrong
so you might believe it but you'll
create enough layers to protect your ego
to the point where you justify what you
did was wrong well in that case and
then you do have to kill off the ego in
order to develop a healthier mental
compass the a mental compass moral
command that's kind of where I'm at is
like should we create a system in our
society like a like a like if you want
to teach right and how are we gonna get
our society to the next level where
people are we're all like collectively
evolved meant mental style right like
and we're treating each other better and
all that stuff it's like if the root of
that problem is ego in all in in all
cases what is the system that we can
create to find and destroy or reach or
create that self-awareness because they
don't teach this in school well right
but I think it's just too zoomed out for
me I don't know how practical this this
is because I don't know how how to apply
it you know I mean I don't know there is
a system that can help fend off the ego
for people and I think it's also a
luxury to even think about it because
there's also people that are like we're
I'm just trying to feed my children see
about my ego because what you're what
we're focusing on is at your point is
Maslow's hierarchy of needs are not
talking about them I'm talking about how
do we reach past this point where we
think we're at the peak so if if if
there's a if there's a pyramid right so
like all the people down here are just
kind of closer to animal like they're
just reacting to life they're just
[ __ ] all they care about is like
eating and [ __ ] more primal right but
then in each stage of society as things
get safer you have other people taking
care of certain things whatever right
what we're hoping is that civilization
goes past where we are today only
because the climates so crazy we have
like you know still corruption and all
these things and people wars and
whatever right but there's got to be a
time and place in human evolution that
we get past this phase and I think I
don't know if the the next evolution is
physical and body or mental and
consciousness seems collectivism yes
what I think so
like two parts that I see two I think
one part is people that have transcended
a few layers of the Maslow's hierarchy
of needs if they do create a system that
can kill the ego that's awesome for them
but then when you try to apply that to
people that are still just like trying
to survive it's hard to apply that
sister to them because they're like I
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about I'm just trying to like do
this right so there's that part of it
and then the other part of it which is
some people on the hierarchy of needs
they say we're already packed we are
already past that like people that even
making minimum wage are already living
better than Kings than back in the day
so that's where the whole term first of
all problems come around where people I
do have like these primal problem
solving mechanisms in their brain and
since we technically don't have to solve
any life-or-death situation we do jump
to politics or we do jump to things and
make those things bigger than they are
way bigger than they are
yeah but I don't think there's any level
on what scale your time as long as my
hierarchy of needs in order for a human
to get to that second like I guess way
of thought like they have to have these
needs met so it's like yeah I don't
think there's any level on that scale
though on that pyramid that transcends
past the ego just by being on this scale
because I don't think that tends to the
ego well I guess like so you go like
survival right and then there's like
finding your passion and then there's
creativity and then you sort of think of
legacy that's all ego though yeah
exactly so you get to a point where
maybe when you start having the time to
philosophize like what joel has been
doing right then you're able to like
kind of remove yourself from yourself
and go oh [ __ ]
this is who I am and you have time to
think about so like unless you passed
all the way up all of those most people
don't even have the time to think about
self reflect and face are you right and
but then but then you go Buddha right
the rigidness Siddhartha God I just
think afraid
he's already up yeah but he shed all
that stuff you said all the materialism
you shed everything he's [ __ ]
starving skinny his bones he's about to
die and that's when he found his
enlightenment right and he killed his
ego then right so like so I don't think
that that thing tends to that all the
spectrum of I need to survive because me
I need to be alive that is well that's
not really you guys should surviving but
then once you get to next step of life
finding your passion and creation and
all that stuff that's all ego that's all
yes
creating how about striving for
greatness like it's all you go like and
and I don't know if there's anything
wrong with it necessarily as long as
you're not destroying people in your
path exactly well it depends on who's
trying yes and destroying someone
because even if we like let's say we
came out with our movie right and if
[ __ ] it smashes and we win an Academy
Award for it we just read all the
competitors ya know it's the same [ __ ]
is like if you're an NFL football team
it's like go take somebody else's job
like it's the same idea yeah so but
there is it but there is a degree of
like you know also don't Tonya Harding
people right I do it the legit way don't
just [ __ ] lead pipe someone's knee
because you want to win a [ __ ]
skating competition I do believe that
having an ego is a part of humanity
though because it's like it'll always be
there
yeah preservation right but then I maybe
then it's not that you go maybe it's
just like self awareness which people
all think they have but they don't have
they don't I think I think some of us
have too much of it too much self
awareness I do yeah so what ends up
happening if you have too much self
awareness I think that you I think that
well I mean not here when we get
questions on the patreon or on me and
Nikki's podcast it's a lot of people are
like I'm afraid to actually do this
because I think that maybe I'm not good
enough and like I'm too self aware of my
own imperfections and I don't not is
that self aware though I don't know if
that's okay it's secured yeah but they
kind of go hand in hand a little bit
right well no because if like if a
girl's going like well like I'm not like
smart enough to do it but everyone
around her is probably like but you're
[ __ ] smart well right but but she is
self-aware and
far as she's recognizing that she lacks
something and and she's like I think
that this is a problem for me or maybe
she just has a hard time believing that
she is smart yeah that's why I'm saying
you're not self-aware then that's well
maybe not but but but I think that there
is a level of self-awareness that gets a
little too too harsh sometimes for
people that and maybe that's maybe the
wrong term but yeah I encounter all the
time it's one of the common most common
things we get when we do q and A's or
anything else is people who are like hey
it's more like self-consciousness or
self your self-esteem is is maybe on a
lower end or you're looking at you
you're choosing to look at the the lower
self yeah if you only if you only focus
on it right but self-awareness is about
taking your your benefit like your goods
and your Bad's and putting them together
and assessing your strengths and
weaknesses
that's upward I think it's very healthy
but I think it can be very destructive
to where you don't step out into the
light if you think yeah exactly
cuz also your subtle what does this I
mean is king super like crazy no I'm
like my brain is I know this is fun like
you're being self-aware that's even
yourself awareness
you're still not looking at the truth
because your self-awareness is askew is
subjective Thank You Bart and that's
what I mean by everything is a
perception so when I've been working on
subconscious things right it's it blew
my mind when I realize this is that the
level of control that I thought over
mine I had over my world I thought it
was a big control until I realized that
you can really skew whatever the [ __ ]
you want your reality to be to the point
where you're in la-la land and you're
like having the time of your [ __ ]
life and that everyone around you is
like this is wrong this is not what
reality is but how many times have we
seen people manifest the [ __ ] out of
their lives from just being batshit
crazy and believing it such as Kanye
West and they're not software exactly
yeah you're right it's just a
manifesting a perception then you're not
jealous ISM yeah because they there they
don't just step out into the light they
step in the light and it with jazz hands
I'm the best person here and it's a
little bit nuts I remember seeing Kanye
on I think it was Letterman a couple
years ago and he was like I'm [ __ ]
genius
and everyone laughed in the audience
he's like no I'm [ __ ] genius nope
[ __ ] remember yeah so so how do you
argue with that - especially when he has
really set his path now and if you look
back if you think it was silly that he
call himself a genius then you look even
sillier now because he's worth the
billion dollars he's only proven his
point more and more and is it I got old
insecure the audience is insecure looks
at him I go you're not a genius right
but we are we just scared to admit that
he really is a genius yeah and is it
delusion if he actually executes sit or
is that good will goes back on the
confidence thing - I think someone's
extreme high confidence freaks most
people out it does you meet some that's
extremely confident and in confidence
like I might be more confident in
another person and my confidence could
could could be like overbearing for
someone else but then when I meet
something that's really confident and
I'm like oh [ __ ] that's confidence it's
hella dude and it's like oh [ __ ] and
then they kind of trample is even it
freaks you out a little bit you know and
you're kinda like what what drugs are
you taking or what vitamins are you're
eating you know but honestly - that's
scary - right cuz then they can't watch
a movie a movie without seeing
themselves in it constantly and they
can't watch anything or see a magazine
cover without thinking of themselves on
the on that cover and so that's when it
becomes a little bit nuts - yeah I
totally become famous and have a billion
dollars and then they success amendment
but then if they don't and in fact they
only have society to blame right
everyone everyone didn't get them they
all suck they were all stupid yeah
that's true for every Kanye there's
there's someone that also has the same
amount of confidence and belief in
themselves but don't carry the same
successes there's ten thousand ten
exactly I mean there's like lists like a
bunch of fighter and coach interviews
all the time and like there's coaches
all over the world they're sailing for
every champion that I produced I have a
guy in the gym that's literally just as
good and you can't even break past like
the amateur realm so what's the only
thing that's different like the calm
like yeah the mindset is like I have the
same I'm a guy with the same skillset he
beats the [ __ ] out of the champion in
training we throw them in like actual
ring with people and he freezes up and I
and then you hear that all the time you
know like and even like even amongst our
friends that his friends that we train
with or like do this guy so much
potential how come they don't go to the
mix and there's just so much other
things but what do greats do like what
did you Michael Jordan do he wouldn't
stop practicing so I know a lot of
people who want to do certain things but
they don't practice and that thing that
they want to be great at so they're more
like in so there's a difference between
entitlement someone who feels like they
should need it already and they don't do
the practice but then there's the other
person who believes in themselves but
they work perfuses they [ __ ] crazy
push hard to get what they want then
there's a third one who I'm like I'm
image great
I have image greatness but ultimately
it's a big to liars yeah it's a vessel
they don't have the the scruples of the
the backing to really say I actually am
this
humans are so confident I think and then
kind of taking on the whole fire thing
and like finding someone that has
confidence but there's also a really
self-aware and doesn't have the ego I
would say max Holloway is that for me
whereas like when he does lose he's very
gracious and he's also in that arrogant
either Behance confidence it's like it's
like they're very [ __ ] fine he's just
Hawaii competences you know you don't
have to blow your own horn because
everyone else is going on yeah you don't
know confidence is calmness to me what
if they're not blowing their horn hard
enough do you got a blow yeah I love it
we weren't high for that episode by the
way welcome to my brain
[Music]